research study in psychology found out
that both
second person and third person makes you
more
it makes yourself talk more powerful so
if you're gonna do affirmations
you wouldn't just say i wanna do this i
wanna do this you wanna do what
we call in the book self-coaching where
you would say
you know in my case yeah brendan it's
important you do a good job here today
because you usually don't do interviews
and you really love marie and you want
to do a good job for her
and her people and this is a book you
worked on for three years and it's
important it does well
and brendan don't forget you're so lucky
you get to do this brother
so just enjoy the process you're so
lucky brendan
that's a different level of going i'm
lucky i'm lucky right
it is i'm brendan yes another one
another one i do every morning
yeah assuming i take a shower but every
morning the shower because we all don't
every day
not every morning no we do not just
doesn't happen it does not happen
i told you like 24 hours ago i was
staying in a barn in the woods at a
friend's house yeah
um but the second thing i asked myself
in the in the shower every morning
is what might happen today that could
trip me up
and how are you going to bring your best
self to that brendan
i say that every morning in the shower
to myself and it just helps me
anticipate
you know something's going to go wrong
during the day absolutely and if i
already know
everything like like this morning's was
okay
you're in i think what we would i think
i'm yes
north manhattan where i'm staying what
do you call it north you're uptown
i'm uptown and you're coming to um let's
just call it downtown
okay so i'm like okay that's gonna be 45
minutes it's a hot summer day yes
i'm gonna get hot and i know when i'm
hot sometimes i get
impatient yes and i get stressed and i
don't want to feel that so just pay
attention to how you're feeling on your
way down to the interview with marie
brendan
and really just engage pay attention be
present with new york
and really enjoy that you're here i know
that sounds completely crazy
but every high performing athlete does
it every salesperson
does it i mean at high level every
person i interviewed who are at what we
call the top 15
of all high performers they all
self-talk and
most of them we found we're doing it in
second and third person
which is amazing i love it yeah i think
it's so fun yeah little things
yeah so if you already talk to yourself
and you say your name to yourself
they're not crazy you're probably high
performing transitions takes place in
the chapter of generate energy and also
maybe it's in productivity too
uh and it has this converse it's just a
conversation
that if you're go go go all the time
you're depleting energy all day and you
don't know it and lots of people think
to get more energy or more productive
they have to radically change your life
i'd better work out an extra 60 minutes
in the morning it's like
actually let me teach you the mastery of
managing transitions
when you go from one activity to another
i want to teach you the simple thing
and that is release tension set
intention
very simple let me give you an example
because it really helps if
you're doing email and you know that
that takes one part of you
your your psyche and brain to do a lot
of email
and now you're gonna go create that
keynote or that powerpoint presentation
that you want to be
flowing and visual and beautiful very
different things
what most people do is they'll do their
email and then they'll work a little on
the presentation then the notification
come over here and then go back to the
email and then
they're multitasking and they're
wrecking not only their measurable
creativity but their long-term
performance
and so what you have to do is when you
finish the email stop it
okay maybe go get some water come back
or whatever
even if you don't all we do push away
from your chair for a minute
close your eyes repeat the word release
with the goal of releasing tension in
your body
and repeat the word release yourself
several times over and over like a
mantra
okay just repeat it could be 60 seconds
it could be one minute it can be two
minutes whatever you want to
just do it until you feel like your body
and your mind release a little bit
then before you open your eyes set an
intention
say okay brendan you're going to work on
this keynote now
your intention is to make something that
grabs them right at the beginning and
then make it really
move fast and make it um make it visual
and make sure that it builds emotionally
throughout the thing so when you make a
call to action at the end bam
and then open my eyes now work on
presentation i'm
clean and free from the previous
activity yes
and people will feel an unbelievable
amount of energetic just
power come back from there i interviewed
or i've worked with
uh a major founder in the startup
silicon valley world flew me down at 3
00 am and
i guess it was around after midnight on
private jet it was
great he was having a lot of trouble
just exhausted
literally depleted um you know this
person's incredibly well valued in his
company
lots of employees everyone knows who the
person would be
but miserable just go go go go go go
and i said let's go and one of his major
things was he was wrecking his
relationship with his wife and his
children
because not because he was maybe just
overworking
he would just carry a lot of the work
into his house yep so when i say i said
i want you to pull up to your house
after the day of working don't get out
of the car
pull up the pull up the house just close
your eyes
repeat the mantra release yourself maybe
five minutes
and then before you open your eyes set
the intention how do you want to be with
your wife
when you enter the house what kind of
dad do you want to be to your daughter
just set that intention open up your
eyes now go in as a different man
and it changed his life his email to me
is in the beginning
it's fantastic it just works that means
just
release tension yep set intention it's
just
your transitions are where most people
is bleeding out their energy and they
don't know
and if we can just get you four or five
times of transition really well
throughout the day
you finish your day like i feel amazing
yes and we didn't we didn't caffeinate
you we didn't do
anything we just changed how you
approach your work
the most important thing i know this
sounds so so silly but common sense is
not always common practice and that's
why so many potentially great people
fail to ever achieve
their potential and that's this listen
you have to get your visualization game
down visualization that means listen
when i wake up when i got a dream
i wake up in the morning before i go to
bed i close my eyes i just see it
happening a little bit and i'll lay in
bed and let my
mind and my body stir up a little bit of
excitement
or sometimes even anxiety about seeing
the actual thing that i want happen
that was for me at one part of my life
seeing myself on stages
speaking and training to people one part
of my life it was seeing
my book come out and seeing it on the
new york times bestseller list or seeing
it on the amazon
bestseller list it was sometimes seeing
myself
coaching major celebrities or sitting
side by side with an oprah winfrey or
tony robbins or
larry king all of which i've been able
to do it was because i
visualized what i really wanted but
here's the thing it's not just
visualization
that's like the first part it's also
affect
we talk about high performance and in
psychology about this thing called
affect which is basically
feelings and emotions i i want you to
allow yourself to literally not just
kind of casually see it like put
yourself there
and feel it and sense it and see it and
feel it and
drink it in like really take in the
ambiance the circumstances
like really visualize and feel
what you are seeing that's so key i mean
as silly as this is
i literally would lay there and i'm like
okay if i'm going to feel
like feel like fill out the ideal
thing what questions would i ask to
really get it going i just start
literally seeing myself at my desk in
the morning
feeling filling out the high performance
planner thinking about other people
worldwide filling out at the same time
as me
and knowing that i got this tribe of
people on this path
of trying to be their best with me and
imagining people coming up and says oh
my gosh
you know brandon you completely changed
my morning you completely changed my
weekly routine you completely changed my
life because
i never tracked my habits before i never
assessed my balance every single week
between
family friends work finances adventure
learning etc everything every tool that
we put in here i could just imagine
someone come up and say brandon i really
appreciate that part
and i literally just thought about it
because i wanted it
to feel like you know i was excited for
the project otherwise what look how easy
it is to diminish anything in our lives
well it's just a book it's just a
planner it's just a
it's just a video it's just a cosmetic
line it's just a beauty thing it's just
that like we all diminish our dreams
we make excuses and we make our dreams
like ah
we throw it away because we're scared to
feel it you know what i'm saying
it's easier to throw it away that's no
big deal avoid it not no problem
and we mess up i want you to feel it
stop detaching from your dreams stop
avoiding that anxious scary feeling of
thinking how hard it's going to be and
thinking how great it's going to be
because most people just they don't even
think about it because it causes too
much nerves i'm like
dancing those nerves a little bit let
them come up for you because that's fuel
man
that's fuel it's like less brown
toddlers you gotta be hungry you'll
never be hungry if you don't visualize
it see it feel it and want it
i really believe most people are
terrified of embarrassment they might
call it something else
but they're scared of embarrassment i
just put this video out
where it starts for the first line is
you're not scared to start your dream
you're embarrassed to be seen starting
small and it just blew up on social
media for us
i think i got more direct messages on
that one little post than anything i've
ever done
and uh people really resonated with it
and because if you think about the truth
about it is
that's what it is for a lot of people
they don't if they quit their job and
they go to start something new
they don't want all their former you
know people to see them
doing something that looks the you know
new and fresh and
and maybe ugly or not put together
they're scared to be embarrassed
and have other people judge them they're
scared
they might use different language well
you know you know they might say well
i'm just
fearful but if you really dig down the
fearful most people are just scared to
be embarrassed
they're scared to try something and
obviously fail at it
and the perception of that failure
really shuts them down
so we have to ask different questions
and i ask this all the time
i literally use the word embarrassment i
said listen i'll say something like are
you not going to try this
before we even get to this like you can
see it you made it happen
are you not going to try it because
you're scared of what somebody else
might think are you not going to try it
because you're scared of somebody
of what somebody else might think i ask
that all the time
and almost all the time people go
well you know i'm not scared but uh you
know i'm worried what my spouse will
think
oh i'm not scared but yeah you know the
people at work might think i'm a little
crazy
and i'll explore that with them because
if we can't get them
over that line of embarrassment and the
willingness
for trial and error we won't get them to
do anything and so my way
through embarrassment for for me
is two different ways just depending on
who the person is
when i hear that someone might be
embarrassed to do something
i'll often start with that past attempt
conversation
have you tried something like this
before and people were horrible to you
and they're always like well no i've
never tried this before
oh so you're making an assumption that
you'd feel uncomfortable but then i also
want to give them permission of like
is this dream worth having a few people
think you're crazy
is this dream worth having a few people
think you're crazy and i'll open up that
dialogue well yeah
okay well who might think you're crazy
well my spouse is going to think i'm
crazy
cool how are they going to communicate
that to you they're going to call me
stupid have they ever called you stupid
before
well no or yes they have i say okay so
you survived it last time they called
you stupid would it be worth surviving
it again
if they call you stupid if you felt
better because you actually got momentum
towards something that matters to you
like oh
yeah and listen knowing that a big frame
here
and helping people get over excuses is
getting them tied back to
is what they are after important i
brought that up earlier
how important is this to you do you
really want this well if
you said that's important isn't it worth
a little discomfort haven't you been
discomforted before
haven't you felt judged and stupid
before
okay so you know you'll survive that now
the question is so the question is about
survival right
let's say yeah it's not about survival
great question is about survival
sounds to me like the real question is
whether you want it we know you'll
survive
i'm curious what if we know you'll
survive
what will it feel like if you're
thriving would it be worthwhile
to have a few doubters or to look stupid
or be seen as silly
if you woke up energized by what you
were doing would that be worth it
high performers are not dissatisfied
strivers
they're not they're happy high
performers are happier
than their peers we all believe that to
get the top it's going to be lonely at
the top
and we all believe you have to grind and
kill yourself to get there yeah and
that's completely wrong
and the data proves it worldwide which
is i think just
overcoming a lot of people's biases
about how you work today because right
now
especially today like you know grind on
social media is so popular or hustle
or hustle and by the way none of the top
15
of high performers worldwide identify
with those words
they literally don't we asked them we
did a whole keyword analysis yep
this was actually pretty cool and high
performers explicitly say
these these are three driving feelings
if we said there was a high performance
state
it's driven from these three things
number one full engagement
yes number two joy yes
and number three confidence yes that's
what they relate with
okay that's where it's coming from it's
a joyous journey
not a dissatisfied one and this i had
this conversation in the book
um because uh i kind of maybe
frame it this way each of these chapters
opens with
a vignette of somebody i worked with or
a
situation that i was in that
demonstrated high performance in this
particular situation
i'm walking on stage thousands of people
after a very famous musician was out
there and was telling the audience that
that person's secret to success remember
thousands of people yes their secret to
that person their whole speech their
secret to success was
never settle never settle
nothing is enough never settle and never
be satisfied
never be satisfied always demand more
and i'm like oh
my second slide which is gonna be on
jumbotron's in like
80 point text was strive
satisfied i'm like oh i'm gonna have to
dispel this for all these thousands of
people i was totally freaked out yeah
and but what i had to explain to people
was not only the data
but it's this uh if you're never
satisfied
i mean what is it true that life is
precious
if it's true that life is precious and
you could be gone tomorrow
do you really want to think you know
what i just never felt fulfilled
i never allowed myself to have a moment
of credit i never allowed myself to have
a moment of peace i never
allowed myself to look at that and say
good job
that's not the way to live life right i
think just at a spiritual level it's a
bad
move and this book doesn't really go in
a lot of that it's more about the
science
and the heart stuff but i think it's
really important that people realize
your job is to strive satisfied and if
you strive satisfied more
often you will be more of a high
performer
and if you never give yourself credit
you're always beating up on yourself
you're always thinking that's not
perfect enough
then what's going to happen dissatisfied
people burn out and they quit
more often than satisfied strivers
so take joy in the moment engage with
what you're doing
allow credit and satisfaction enjoy to
come in you can always be improving
of course but be proving be improving
joyfully yes and if you're improving
joyfully then
you're learning you feel curious you
feel engaged the joy is there
you'll get more confident because you're
like i'm gonna learn through this anyway
this can be great
because you know this this thing is all
over social media right now like
you know grind work whatever and i'm
like it's just it's popular and i see
why that happens
and i see why it's catchy it's just not
scientifically valid
one of the major major keys we found the
first high-performing habit
is seek clarity and what we found
is one of the practices that high
performers do
is they define the feeling they're after
and so when we had to explain that and
later
talk about it in the energy chapter we
had to differentiate between feelings
and emotions and they are different
emotions tend to be they're the same
like we have they're physical they're
almost always automatic even though when
the brain is creating associations
there's also happen
for us it's kind of emotion comes up
yeah you're watching a movie and you're
just sad and you're like oh my gosh you
know i'm crying
you didn't even have the tissues right
you're just like rock you know uh
but the feelings are usually
interpretations that we make
of what that emotion was and how it
sticks and the meaning we give it to it
yeah and the example i used
you know i like to give and i don't
remember if it's in the book or not
honestly because here's what's happened
this book is 400 pages it was 1481 when
i finished
baby you edited it down yes and it was 1
1481
good complete like it was like awesome
yes but i was like that's going to freak
people out so we're publishing a bunch
in academic journals later and then
stripped it down to 400 pages so it's
more readable and fun and orientable so
i can't remember if this one actually
made it in there but
um the example i like to give is if you
and i go to
a haunted house yeah which i love i love
them i love them and they scare me the
crap but if
you and i walk around you know you walk
around on the walls in a haunted house
come jumps out at you yeah you and i are
both gonna jump yes
we are emotionally going to experience
fright
immediately it's going to be there right
but i might be
freaked out for the next five minutes
and you might be laughing
why it's the meaning and the feeling
that we've defined it as
that's fine for everybody here's the
issue that people have and you have to
be careful about
when we start talking about energy
because emotional energy is real yes
and that is look if at six like we go to
the haunted house at you know 5 p.m in
the afternoon
if at 9 00 pm now you're in your house
you're alone but you're completely safe
and you still
feel scared that's not the haunted
house's problem
that is the way that you are defining
and working through your own emotions
you had the emotion of terror and fear
and you're still
experiencing that feeling that's a
mental job
not an emotional job so your job is to
go wow
i'm at my house i've i've lived here for
10 years i've never been threatened this
house this is a safe place
i got to redefine the feeling i want to
experience and i work with one an
olympic sprinter gold medalist
olympic sprinter as a client and
this person's huge breakthrough in
getting better
and going from literally uh one olympics
before
not meddling at all to now gold i said
what made
like what was the thing yeah and one of
the things they said to me was
i learned to define the feeling
and i said what do you mean by that and
he basically said you know
if if if if there's a bunch of us at the
starting box and we're all in perfect
poise and perfect condition
the one to bet on is the one that says
this is the way i want to feel in this
race right now
i know my emotions are going crazy like
my heart's beating i can hear
everybody i'm waiting for that shot
blast i i can see my goal
i know how important this is and all
these like these their emotions are
there yeah but that person is defining
the feeling going
i'm going to feel centered now i'm going
to get myself
in the zone now even though the anxiety
is the emotion of anxiety is there
for all olympic level competitors all of
them
but they define that feat that emotion
as a feeling
that helps give them a performance edge
and i think that's important too you
know bruce springsteen says
if he's ever backstage and doesn't feel
like
nerves he's going to hang it up but
that's anxiety he's just defining it
differently
i've always really worked extremely hard
to maintain
an incredible level of energy in my
mental body
my i'm sorry in my you know mental
emotional physical
spiritual being just trying to do
everything i can from
the way that i work out to what i
consume to what i don't consume
to how i rest to how i meditate to how i
recover like everything in my life has
always been about how do i bring the joy
and if i'm going to generate the energy
i want to create for you guys
how do i do that specifically well i've
always got these routines and everything
else but what happened this year
i was kind of had my health taken away a
little bit in
mid uh october i got pneumonia
and tonsillitis at the same time while i
was on the road
doing multiple four-day and multiple
five-day
events where i'm kind of the lead
trainer and that kicked my butt and i'm
still honestly recovering from it
like i'm i'm still feeling it i'm still
feeling heading into
the final part of this year i'm still
recovering uh don't worry
clean bill of health doctors like you're
good to go they're just your body's
maybe recovering you'd be
tired for a while and i made it 41 42
years
without feeling fatigue outside of times
of injury
you know i i don't think i've ever had
the flu
i don't really ever get sick when i get
sick it's like sniffles
um but this one was something it just
smacked me i mean i was
down and out it's why i feel like i'm
way behind on my episodes for you all
um it's why i feel like we're launching
a few things in january that i'd hoped
to launch in
you know october so that like
taking care of my health is always been
a priority this year
i learned what it feels like when it's
gone and
many been with me for a long time that
happened in 2011
when i had my brain injury and i snap my
wrist and my ribs
my hip so i'm not you know
new to pain i'm not new to being sick
but this was the first time
where i also with the sickness lost
motivation
you know where it was like even when i
had like when i was really sick in the
past of my life
i would still like wake up in the day
and i'd prime my mind
get excited about what's to come and
just go
this year there was about the last two
months i really had to work on that
there were plenty of days i was just
like
ugh not because i didn't love my life or
i wasn't grateful
or present you've been there before like
when you just you physically feel
terrible
it is hard to get your mind right i was
a
maybe 24 or 25 year old man and i was a
member of kiwanis
and if you guys didn't know kiwanis was
is a it's kind of like
rotary or lions club um it's uh it's a
a it's a non-profit organization that's
dedicated towards service in
in the community and i was in columbus
and i was the youngest one
hands down like in in the room we get
together every single month on a tuesday
and we have lunch and we'd have a
speaker in and then we talked about a
volunteer project we were going to do
that month
and that was kind of how it went in
kiwanis for me and so
i but in my room i was 24 25 in the room
every tuesday um when we got together
everyone else was older i mean they were
like 50s and 60s and 70s older when i
was 20 i was the youngest person in the
room every single time
and i remember i was having a
particularly
challenging time because i was thinking
about quitting my job but i was scared
because i didn't i hadn't saved any
money
i didn't know exactly what i wanted to
do i just knew that
i knew that the job wasn't the thing at
the time
but i didn't know what it was and so i
was scared to make the leap and
i was just i was just kind of struggling
with some existential stuff because
you know it'd been four or five years i
hadn't had a girlfriend
and it was just frustrating i was like
dating but i wasn't able
i just wasn't making real connections on
when i was dating and i was just
unhappy in that part of my life i didn't
know what i was doing with my career i
didn't have a significant relationship i
was like oh man
i'm just kind of i didn't feel good and
so i was having a really
down day on that particular tuesday and
i went in and i was sitting next to this
guy
and he was one of the just one of the
awesome kawanians that who was there and
he was um i think he was probably 59
60 years old he was in banking um very
successful wealthy guy happy hap just
he was like a happy-go-lucky grandpa
type you know just a good dude
and i'm just kind of listing off to him
all these things that suck
you know and he says what are you doing
about it and i said well you know i
you know and he says well i bet and he
said i bet i know what's going on he's
you're going home you're probably
watching too much tv drinking too much
beer and
sitting alone too often or you're going
out not having any fun and
we're just talking my mode was yeah i
kind of i go inside so i kind of
pull away from people when i'm unhappy
and so i was like yeah i kind of pull
away and i'm in my house
and he says why i know how to solve your
problem
i said oh what is it he goes buy tickets
i'm like buy ticket when he even buy
tickets he goes i want you to
open up the paper remember the papers
says i want you to open up the paper
and he goes i want you to see what's
going on in your town and i want you to
buy tickets
to whatever's coming up the next seven
weekends
is it is there a symphony coming to town
buy tickets
is there a ballet buy tickets is there a
an art museum buy tickets is there he
said
is there a concert buy tickets and i
said what do you mean i
buy tickets i want you to buy one two
three four tickets and i want you to
take your friends and i just want you to
go
i want you to buy tickets and i want you
to go and i'm like what the hell
does this have to do with anything i'm
even talking about
he goes just buy the tickets and come
back next month tell me about the
tickets
and i'm like no and he literally pulls
out his wallet
and i'll never forget he sets down three
100
bills and he goes buy the tickets
here's the money and i'm like what do
you even i was literally so frustrated
it's a
long story short i'll try to keep it
shorter but so i bought tickets i got
like a symphony ticket i uh got a there
was like a dance troupe in town or
something weird
there's a dave matthews concert and what
else is there's one other thing i can't
remember what it was
uh shoot there's something about the
tickets i went with one or two or three
friends
and went to them and the
second i remember even i remember the
opening
act for the dave matthews band started
and i was like
got it got it because sometimes when
you're down and out
you got to get out and about and so
i was down and out and he got me out and
about and then with you with your
friends and you're socializing and it's
in a new environment
and things are happening and my mind
just started turning on again
i started getting all these ideas and
these dreams that i don't know where
they were they weren't in my room they
weren't in my bed
these ideas and dreams they weren't
happening in my journal
the the the ideas and dreams they
weren't happening in my my daily planner
it was like i was stuck there so he
moved me over here
have you ever been like at a ballet or a
symphony in orchestra
and you're just sitting there and all of
a sudden
you feel amazing like the music hits you
this idea comes in and you walk out and
you
feel amazing have you ever gone to
broadway show you went in and you were
frustrated and freaked out because all
the
horrible new york traffic and all of a
sudden you
laugh your ass off and you leave the
broadway show and you feel like a
million dollars
and now no problem is going to slow you
down
that's buy tickets buy tickets to
seminar
buy tickets to the event buy tickets the
art museum the ballet
buy tickets and i mean if you're down
and out and your life sucks right now
go buy tickets for the next four weeks
and i promise you'll be like
damn buy tickets that changed my life
changed my life too and i've learned
ever since then like if i'm down and now
it's like buy tickets
if you want to see the affirmations
video we did with les brown check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there maybe you've
already given up and maybe you just need
a little fire a little encouragement
to get back in the game again here's
what i want you to look at
they're winners they're losers